thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
the first thousand people to click the
link in the description can get a one
month free trial of skillshare's premium
membership so you can start exploring
your creativity today
[Music]
we recently did an episode about
nematodes the phylum of worm that
outnumbers just about every animal on
this planet now it's not the most
striking of animals but the nematode has
had a few distinguished scientific
decades thanks to its many uses and
laboratories so as far as worms go the
nematode seems to dominate much of our
scientific understanding but worms
despite their seemingly simple bodies
are a diverse bunch which is why we
thought for today it might be fun to
visit with a less famous worm they're
like one of those relatives that you
don't really know very much about but
every time you see him there's a new
strange story to unpack
they are the aeolosomatids a family of
freshwater worms the ones that you see
here are invaders they showed up
uninvited in a blepharisma culture that
james our master of microscopes has been
taken care of for a long time
and while aeolosoma worms are you know
worms they are in a different class of
worm because as we have seen before
there are in fact many ways to be a tube
where nematodes are roundworm's
aeolosoma are segmented placing them in
the anilid phylum along with earthworms
and leeches
aeolosoma are usually several
millimeters in length their bodies
divided into more than 10 segments that
you can see scrunching up and expanding
as the worm wiggles its way through the
microcosmos
the aeolosoma are striking to look at
you can see their organs through their
transparent bodies and as it moves
bundles of long bristly hairs wave along
the side of its body
those hairs mark the aeolosoma as a
specific type of anilid called a
polykete or bristle worm
some bristle worms are found in unusual
places like hydrothermal vents but our
aolosoma come from a much more mundane
home they're usually found in bodies of
fresh water where they'd like to crawl
among the leaves and algae that settle
at the bottom of the water and inside
their bodies are colorful gland cells
though no one is really sure what those
cells exist for or why they have their
particular colors
in some species the cells are green and
others they're yellow and sometimes as
with our worms they're red the final
result is a worm that looks a little
like it ran into a porcupine while also
having caught chicken pox
while there are some aolosoma species
that reproduce sexually most reproduce
asexually dividing to form a copy of
itself the aolosoma creates its clone at
its end linking the old and new versions
of itself like a chain you can see the
new aelosoma here looking like it's
attached to the other's butt because
it's attached to the other's butt
and this chain can keep going as the
aeolosoma keeps dividing adding more
worms that are connected together so
that the final length of their combined
bodies sometimes reaches around 10
millimeters total that's 10 millimeters
of clones combined to create one giant
mega worm until eventually the chain
breaks and they all go their separate
ways
so when james found these worms invading
his samples you'd think maybe this would
be an exciting find here is a culture
full of bristled polka-dotted
chain-forming clones what could be more
exciting
well as wonderful as they are to look at
these invasions are not ideal because
they are also essentially vacuum
cleaners their mouths are lined with
cilia that wave around and help the
worms suction up bits of plant and
animal debris when they're in a pond
they like to crawl across leaves and
algae for their meals but when you find
them in bottles of cillian cultures
you've been lovingly maintaining that's
when things get a bit dicier because
aeolosoma will eat just about anything
including each other
indeed in one very dramatic scene
documented in 1901 scientists observing
the species aeolosoma tenebrarum
described the way these chains of worms
would twist up in each other creating a
writhing tangled ball of worms that
would stay stuck together for long
periods of time
and when the scientists pulled these
balls apart they usually found at least
one worm that had been partially eaten
i'm sure the etiquette around
cannibalistic frenzies varies but for
most animals getting eaten by another
member of your species would seem at the
very least a little rude but when you're
aolosoma it's not that big of a deal
honestly it's not much more than an
inconvenience because if a part of it
gets eaten it can always regenerate
in one case the scientists watching
these balls of worms found that one worm
had its head eaten but in about three
days
it was able to make a new one
it would probably have taken less time
to regenerate other parts of their body
heads seem to take the alosoma a bit
longer perhaps because of all the
complex parts that need to be rebuilt
and the alessoma can regenerate even
when it is cut into multiple segments
this superpower has made one species
called aolosoma viridae particularly
interesting to scientists and it's not
just that they can regenerate after all
as incredible as this ability is there
are plenty of other animals that can
regenerate as well but scientists aren't
just interested in how animals
regenerate they also want to know how
those regenerative abilities change as
the animal gets older
that's a difficult question to study
because as you might expect self-healing
animals have often pretty long lifespans
so it's a challenge to wait years or
even decades to study how their ability
to regenerate changes with the wear and
tear of aging
aolosoma viridi however has a lifespan
of only about two months which means it
goes from young to old on a manageable
time scale for scientists cycling
through experiments and that makes it a
useful organism to observe how that
capacity to rebuild itself changes as
the worm ages
but as useful as regeneration is for
survival it is not the only tool the
worm relies on after all not all dangers
can easily be patched up by rebuilding
body parts sometimes the worm has to
preempt dangerous conditions and for
that it turns to the cyst
in nature the worms will likely begin
forming these cysts in autumn when the
water gets cold and begins to fill with
the remains of decomposing life and as
the temperatures continue to fall the
worms begin to slow down crawling to
areas full of delicious debris for them
to stock up on and eventually the worms
begin to secrete a mucus creating a
gooey shell that then hardens into a
cyst you can see the granules of red
pigment swirling around as the worm
moves inside some of that activity might
be the peristaltic movement of its
intestines but it's also possible that
the warmth of the microscope lamp is
causing the worms to stir as well
and in their ponds when warm weather
comes the worm will get ready to emerge
from its encased hibernation using its
head to push at the hardened case of its
cyst until it manages to poke a hole
through from which it can escape it can
take a worm anywhere from 30 minutes to
several hours to make its exit and if
there's a thick coating of bacteria on
the cyst it may even take the worms
several days
and from there
well it is a life of suction feeding and
chain link clones and regenerating
perhaps not normal to us but what's
normal anyway
especially
when you're a worm
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
we would also like to say thank you
again to skillshare for supporting this
video maybe you're sitting there
thinking i'm tired of watching all these
youtube videos i want to try making some
of my own well that is one of the many
things you can learn to do using
skillshare there you will find the
course filmmaking for content creators
where host aaron palabiob teaches you
how to be an efficient and well-prepared
solo filmmaker whether it's for your own
content or for professional work his
course aims to both demystify the
filmmaking process and empower you to
shoot high quality videos all on your
own skillshare is an online learning
community that can help you make 2022 a
year of new learning growth and
connection through creativity with so
much to explore and real world projects
to create skillshare empowers you to
accomplish real growth it's curated
specifically for learning meaning there
are no ads to distract you and they're
always launching new premium classes so
you can stay focused on leveling up your
skills and if you're one of the first
thousand people to click on the link in
the description you can get a one month
free trial of skillshare's premium
membership
there are a bunch of names on your
screen right now and those names are
tied to people and those people are
individuals who each made an individual
decision
that they would like this content to
exist on the internet and if you feel
like this content should exist on the
internet maybe you would like your name
to be here and that can happen if you
become a patreon patron at patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
you